Michael asks "How do you define Hustle?"
Michael, this if funny because -- show his face, because I can see him grinning
This was the first question -- what are we thirty five (35) in? This if the first question in one hundred fifteen (115) questions
that I can see from the corner of my --
he literally said "How do you define hustle?"
(laughs)
Cause you know
This is a challenging question... so first of all, it's different for everybody, right?
But what I would say hustle is to me, is that when you have passion around something
that you are squeezing every last bit of the juice out of the orange -- right?!
To me, hustle is maximizing the energy you're putting in to somebody.
I'm blown away by people saying that they are hustling and they want to achieve these great things,
and then their actions don't match. It's like saying "You really want to lose weight", while eating a Big Mac, right?
So to me, hustle would be putting all your effort into achieving the goal at hand,
and for me that means making every. minute. count.
Hiring a full time assistant who is, I mean -- Friday night didn't happen... because I was hustling. Every. Minute.
If i've missed my fifteen (15) minutes to tape this show, i've missed my fifteen (15) minutes, because
there is so much hustle in my day, there is no hanging out. There is no time.
If I get to do one joke with you guys as I am walking in between meetings, you find that to be a rare
acquaintance  situation. *Occurrence, not acquaintance*
Hustle is putting it all on the line. Hustle is waking up one day the day before you die, and realizing
you gave it your all, into the parenting of your children, the building of your businesses, the philanthropy that
you wanted to do - what ever you define, it's just.. ya know.. "All In"
emotionally and execution-ally.
In theory, in strategy and in execution.
Subscribe!
I need subscriptions
I can't push this many "Right Hooks" in social.
Subscribe (I appreciate your attention - <3 -G-)